dictators in training that's the focus
of tonight's angle all right after
watching this week's shows many of you
are probably wondering how on earth the
party of FDR and JFK turned so hard left
so fast we showed you how the 2020
Democratic field has become essentially
a parody of itself and expose the
drastic real-world consequences for
America if their true agenda is ever
enacted but now to move forward we need
to back up just a little bit to the
liberal elites tedious refrain about
trump that we've heard ad nauseam for
more than two years today we say to
Donald Trump as clearly as we can that
he is not a dictator he must obey the
Constitution think of the dictators and
tyrants using the exact same language
Trump uses he embraces dictators of all
stripes this is a case study and self
projection they accused Trump of
something of which they themselves are
actually guilty well tonight we will
irrefutably demonstrate that 2020
Democrats like Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie Sanders are much more than just
socialist Crusaders they're dictators in
waiting following their ideas to their
logical conclusion we see that liberals
are no longer determined to raise your
standard of living they are determined
to control nearly every aspect of your
life and this impulse was on full
display during CNN's marathon climate
change for him seven endless hours
filled with enough gas to burn clear
through those own layer Democrat
candidates eagerly touted
multitrillion-dollar plans and promised
that the pain and discomfort that was
going to come would be necessary for
planetary health there will be a
transition there will be a transition
and and there will be some pain there
we're gonna have to ask people to
understand that we have got to make
those chain
Changez now even though they may be a
little bit uncomfortable for the sake of
future generations a little bit
uncomfortable well yeah the government's
gonna control how and when you travel
eventually where you say your thermostat
etc etc but they insist or more
accurately they demand that Americans
abandon all new advances in drilling and
oil and gas exploration there's no
question I'm in favor of banning
fracking banning extractive oil fracking
from public lands going after their
drilling and licensing stopping them for
more coasts you said stop new oil and
gas drilling on federal lands yes here
booker going after their licenses he
ever been to a fracking rig i have
doesn't know what he's talking we're
gonna get into that in a few minutes
the average price by the way of a gallon
of gas in america today it's about two
dollars and fifty seven cents really
good i mean that's like a tax cut and
every mile we drive and every product we
buy it's great news for americans
because after decades of reliance on
Middle East for oil our nation is now
nearly energy independent but if
Democrats have their way and they follow
the UN's lead all Americans could be
paying a hell of a lot more and of
course the rich though they wouldn't
really feel that gas prices because no
middle America will feel at all yeah of
course they would but it's not just
about dictating energy sources Democrats
want to dictate your diet as well should
Americans change their eating habits and
eat less beef it's good for the
environment it's good for your health if
you eat less meat I love cheeseburgers
from time to time but there has to be
also what we do in terms of creating
incentives what you support changing the
dietary guidelines yes you know the food
parent what people yes a reduce red meat
specifically yes I would does she have
an exercise tape out too I mean this is
ridiculous
go away this isn't only though
interested in what you eat but how you
drink do you ban plastic straws
we should yes I mean look I'm gonna be
honest it's really difficult to drink
out of a paper straw but you know let's
let's encourage innovation and anyway I
think we could do a little bit better
than some of those flimsy plastic straws
but we do need to bend the plastic this
is a paper straw off by the way it is
hard to drink out of the Democrat
dictators they don't stop there they
want to police your light sources should
the US government have a say on what
kind of light bulbs we use you know
these light bulbs are in manufactures
they intentionally burn out so there's
an industry and we replace them over and
over again so if anything we should be
pushing regulations that make it so that
our light bulbs consume less energy and
need to be replaced less often what
happened all the you know how many
people does it take to change the light
bulb jokes we wouldn't have those jokes
anymore okay and if you love hauling
your kids around and your chevy suburban
or tooling around your new Toyota
Corolla too bad so will everyone have to
drive electric cars well by my plan by
2045 we will have basically zero
emission vehicles only well there will
still be some legacy gas guzzlers on the
road for quite some time but you are
going to offer to buy the clunker back
and help them upgrade clunker he's
obviously not driven a really awesome
eight cylinder vehicle it's ridiculous a
buyback by the way where have I heard
that one before we're gonna get all the
money to buy all these things back well
of course this is so what we've come to
expect from the new-and-improved
Democrat party because the happier you
are and you're eight cylinder sedan
enjoying an in-and-out burger with more
money in your pocket the more miserable
they are because these Democrat control
freaks they don't want you to be
independent they want you to be
dependent on the crumbs that the
government doles out and I think though
of all of this the most shocking
revelation last night came from Bernie
Sanders because more than just dictating
your transportation and your home
lighting they will eventually seek to
control how many children you have
human population growth has more than
doubled in the past 50 years the planet
cannot sustain this growth
would you be courageous enough to
discuss this issue monthly the answer is
yes and the Mexico City Agreement which
denies American aid to those
organizations around the world that are
that allow women to have abortions or
even get involved in birth control to me
is totally absurd so I think especially
in poor countries around the world where
women do not necessarily want to have
large numbers of babies something I very
very strongly support state plan
families a modified one-child policy got
it
well perhaps Bernie can roll out his own
one-child policy that will make the
Chinese proud now remember it's all for
the good of the planet no sacrifice is
too great
as long as it's mostly on the shoulders
of the poor in the middle class an
Liberals have the gall after everything
you've heard this week on the angle they
have the gall to call Trump a tyrant
these are the most controlling people on
the face of the planet as long as
they're making all the decisions
so by electing any one of these top-tier
Democrats you would be relinquishing
your choices your right to determine
your own destiny you really want to see
that play out in our country I don't
think so and that's the angle